hello welcome to this video play our
penguin whoa must be one of the best
scores i have 10.5 over 12 i have
against this player and it's a lot III
ok let's that's possible set up not not
very popular but I came mother capture
I'm never really afraid of much but it's
very solid
94 is probably a bad idea no ledges
cover
you
he isn't detected yet but some extra
protection for that porn probably this
okay
yeah I'll just shoot for fluent
development team doing anything fancy
maybeee for and 94 is some possible now
no like it's not not great but
let's see what he does so it's not that
is if you want to play okay so this
means here we can see three quite a bit
before I can do that you form night
somewhere and then I'll night
before night d 495 but not completely
sure about this it looks good though he
might go to the tool I I shoulda thought
about that one night it was better
hmm that's not good yeah no I don't have
not you have available and he threatens
night xe4 immediately
ok I think I have to make use of the
tempo possibly Bishop f5 next
she takes f6 out I will take with the
pawn I mean it's not so clear that that
this is bad at least I don't see it
because I have some play on the D file
it's not like this is nothing but let's
not be so quick here and it looks good
yeah i'm attacking that rook what is his
move now back almost so probably just
this night before coming here it looks
good that looks good for me right be4 up
t to
and the night is not going anywhere and
I think one can also just go see five
this is what I was thinking yeah let's
do this prevent any 94 it was the main
idea of night before I wanted to make
sure that I get c5 and so that 94s never
never on ok route d 2 nite c 2 also was
pretty good yeah I should have done that
actually so let's go a three yeah
somehow I seem to have this guy's number
night is trapped trapped on b5 ok I can
go to a seven but I'm certainly ok yeah
um what now Bishop g6 let's just let's
just drop this back
yam so a 5 has that dangerous not much
I can stop it though why not
check well okay that accelerates light
resigns yeah there's some sometimes they
match up that don't work I mean for one
player and okay I'm quite higher rated
and usually I'm higher than 2 3 30 so
I'm the favorite against the sky but and
I now I now have 11 and a half out of 13
one lost one draw a line wins yeah that
looked kind of okay i think most of the
time my position seemed fine i never
believed in that capture only five lines
much because black's pieces are very
decent and something like that that can
never be really bad for black you have
every piece and play and I mean yeah two
bishops but they don't do that much yet
at best that is a very slight ash for
wide and this I know it just Ricans died
we considered III how the computer wants
to go here and claims the big edge
already I was always reluctant to do
this kind of thing because of that pin I
care the engine has a technical solution
between f6 that's indeed nice okay but
that is interesting as well yeah i get i
get space t3 is a weakness and this this
was not play but at all night that be
one is now now that does that doesn't
work at all 25 and now exactly this yeah
just just how I played is six is even
better than that but I'm winning so it's
okay yeah that that was it was of course
a bit simpler
okay he cannot play that position with
the with the night on b5 yeah I'm just
yeah basically Jack picking up the
picking up the pieces here yeah
sometimes you have those those
mismatches somehow where one side is
killing the other score wise and you
don't really know why okay thanks for
watching